grenze überschritten höhere
krankenkassenbeiträge für ungeimpfte
bayerns gesundheitsminister klaus
holetschek schlägt das vor und wir
wollen darüber diskutieren mit dem chef
der kassenärzte in deutschland andreas
kassen schönen guten tag herr gassen
das hört man auch hat man auch gerade
bei uns immer wieder auf der straße
gehört also die einen lehnen das ab und
die anderen sagen wer bis heute sich
nicht hat impfen lassen für den muss ich
doch mit zahlen dann muss der auch
höhere beiträge zahlen klaus holetschek
bayerns gesundheitsminister fordert das
was halten sie davon
ich halte wenig von weil das was von den
beiträgen zum teil zu hören weil ich
zahle dafür ihren damit das ist das
prinzip einer solidar versicherung das
im grundsatz alle in eine gemeinsame
versicherung einzahlen und eben nicht
das wieder rausnehmen was ihr einzel
sondern dass das den zugute kommt die
krank werden und wenn man das wohl jeder
aggressiver an der stelle aufbricht dann
gibt es viele andere dinge wo man das
mit sehr guten gründen auch machen
könnte medizinisch begründet stellt sich
vor jeden tag sterben und 350 menschen
am dekotieren infolge des nikotinkonsums
denken sie an übergewichtige die
diabetes haben viele andere dinge bin
einem gefallen das ist aber das was mir
der gesetzlichen kann was ich eigentlich
nicht kennen risikoadjustierte beiträge
das ist das wesen der privaten
krankenversicherung da wird das
entsprechend eingepreist dann sind die
beiträge mal höher insofern glaube ich
ist das nicht wenig nicht wirklich
praktikabel ich finde es auch nicht
vereinbar mit unseren gedanken der
solidarischen krankenversicherung und
realistischerweise wird es in vielen
fällen dazu kommen dass die kosten
überhaupt nicht einzutreiben sind bei
dir sehr schnell enorme höhen erreichen
können die für normalbürger gangs
leisten insofern ist das ein vorschlag
der ziemlich
am ziel vorbei jetzt will ich mal sagen
also dass wartet er die fronten ist
nicht praktikabel und widerspricht
grundzügen unserer gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung hergarten sie sagen
das wäre nicht praktikabel wissen die
kassen denn überhaupt wer geimpft und
wer um geimpft ist wir wissen ja wenn
niemandem werde ebenso unglücklich dass
wir sind im zweifel auch nicht ob jemand
raucht oder ob jemand risikosportart
dass da fängt das ganze allein mit dem
impf mit der impfpflicht schon an wir
müssen erst mal einen ins register haben
das gibt es bislang nicht das müsste man
daten sicher erkennbar der oberste
datenschützer dass schon kritisch
angemerkt daten sicher darstellen dann
muss das gemeldet wenn ich weiß wie wir
das tun soll das ak oder wer auch immer
also das ist auch nicht über nacht aus
dem boden zu stampfen das sind alles
dinge die bringen uns nicht wirklich
weiteren machen aus meiner sicht ja das
gegenteil die leute werden davon nur
irritiert und fronten verhärten sich wir
sollten vielmehr in aufklärung
investieren das zeigt hier dass das
tatsächlich jetzt auch funktion wir
haben ja steigenden zahlen und ich habe
von schön gesagt die regierung hat das
eben versprechen eingelöst ich will
sagen die kolleginnen und kollegen
gegeben haben dass ihm versprechen der
bundesregierung eingelesen und ich würde
sagen ich würde sagen wir haben das eben
versprechen eingelöst weil wir uns alle
haben impfen lassen mittlerweile wir
haben's eingelöst vergessen danke für
ihre hilfe auch für die vorgabe dieses
ziels fand ihn kanzler olaf scholz aber
die die sich haben impfen lassen die
haben es doch geschafft letztlich ist
das so also
jetzt platzt uns hier karl lauterbach
plötzlich in das nehmen wir gleich eine
firma auf die wahl aber nochmal bei dem
kleinen lob für die 30 millionen der
gassen ja das ist prima und ich freue
mich für jeden der sich
aus überzeugung impfen lässt weil wir
wissen dass ist ändert sich nicht impfen
ist der weg aus der pandemie und jeder
schützt sich damit letzten endes auch
die anderen bisschen aber im
wesentlichen die dual schutz und
vielleicht noch die die sahne auf der
torte schützt ja nicht nur vor schwere
erkrankung vor tod wir wissen
mittlerweile auch dass geimpfte 1 in
sehr seltenen fällen überhaupt noch
anderen kugeln er kann können also
selbst wenn bildet verläufe die
möglicherweise von cobit nach sich
ziehen könnten
verlieren durch die impfung schon ihren
strecken also von daher gibt es viele
gute sachliche medizinische gründe sich
impfen zu lassen ich glaube da bei uns
noch gar nicht mit zwang arbeiten aber
wir müssen das den leuten nahebringen
insbesondere denen die sprachbarrieren
haben ich glaube da ist noch einiges zu
heben an möglichen impfquoten und
eigentlich wäre es doch auch viel
sinnvoller den spieß umzudrehen und den
vielleicht eine prämie auszuschütten die
sich haben impfen lassen oder
ich weiß gar nicht ob mein prämien
braucht also die menschen sich impfen
lassen haben wir den gewinn dass sie gut
geschützt sind und das ist ja glaube ich
das wichtigste man macht so was ja nicht
um einkaufsgutschein irgendwo zu
bekommen sondern man macht es weil man
sich und seine lieben schützen will und
im zweiten in der zweiten reihe
natürlich auch die anderen mitbürger
aber von daher glaube ich jeder
profitiert durch die impfung unmittelbar
persönlich da brauchst meine fans keine
prämien was wir brauchen ist wirklich
eine zielgruppengerechte aufklärung und
ansprache da haben wir davon haben wir
zu wenig gemacht ich glaube da kann man
noch mehr machen und da soll die energie
drauf legen anstatt immer neue
abgrenzung szenarien aufzuzeigen das
glaube ich bringt nur gift in die
diskussion und diese bilder von
demonstrationen die man da mit der
tagesschau sie sind ja entsetzlich die
möchten wir nicht sehen jetzt war eben
bei uns im studio ja unser bild meinung
der philippinen hat auch über seine
recherche und nochmal berichtet nämlich
über die zahl der korona patienten in
krankenhäuser nach bildrecherche eben
sind das zwar alles menschen die korona
haben aber nicht alles menschen die
wegen corona ins krankenhaus gekommen
sind wie erklären sich dass das bei
diesen zahlen ja doch ein bisschen
getrickst wurde offenbar
naja aber ausgetrickst ist oder einfach
eine ungenauigkeit wir erleben das ja
nicht überdehnen gemeldet die kosten
sondern auch bei den corona toten werden
ja alle gezählt die mit corona verstehen
wir sind ja nicht alle ausschließlich an
corona verstorbene sofern haben wir
einen enormen bayers also einen
statistischen fehler
dass man so dass solche fehler geht ist
die eine sache ich finde es nur das wäre
sinnvoll und seriös diesen fehler klar
zu benennen um die zahlen ein bisschen
in einem realistischen kontext zu rücken
und eine bessere einordnung zu
ermöglichen
müsste man dass sauberer arbeiten also
müsste man tatsächlich nur die patienten
als corona patienten ausweisen die wegen
corona auch im krankenhaus sind
muss das zumindest daran tun wenn an
diesen zahlen maßnahmen und folgen
abgeleitet werden ganz eklatant war es
zum beispiel bei den zahlen zu den
kindern die im krankenhaus liegen wo man
zahlen in die welt gesetzt und dann die
deutschen selbst vier kinder und
jugendmedizin dass man sofern gerade
gerückt hat dass er gesagt hat naja von
von 15 kindern die mit einem positiven
vortest im krankenhaus liegen liegen ein
bis zwei wegen corona im krankenhaus und
die andere wegen leistenbruch anderer
erkrankungen also das finde ich ist dann
schon gehört dazu man muss schon
statistische fehler klar benennen und
wenn man zahlen für politische maßnahmen
heranzieht dann sollten die belastbar
sein ich finde das ist wird sonst extrem
schwierige diskussion und man verliert
auch vertrauen bei den menschen danke an
den kassen ärzte chef andreas gassen
hierbei bild live auch zu der diskussion
über höhere krankenkassen beiträge für
ungeimpfte diese diskussion werden wir
weiter führen mit dem der genau das
fordert gleich nämlich mit klaus
holetschek bayerns gesundheitsminister
dagegen dankeschön